the International Beauty show is back
here in Las Vegas it's expected to make
a full comeback 8 news now reporter
Victoria Saha spoke with one local lash
artist she shows us what this show means
and how the pandemic had an effect on
the beauty industry
from nails to skin to hair to lashes the
beauty industry is always coming up with
new techniques and products those skills
are displayed at the International
Beauty show where Sue Jin Yang will be
to me I feel like a true last artist has
a human relationship a deep
understanding with their client because
their clients eyes are closed Sujin Yang
is a lush extension artist and founded a
new LED light specifically for lash
extensions called aluminol the beauty
show will be her chance to introduce it
to other lash extension artists that are
expected to flood the convention center
the Halls were empty and you know this
is the first year I have a feeling it's
going to come on really strong during
the pandemic there was no guarantee her
new creation would go anywhere I felt
like I was hit by a bus because I didn't
see it coming like Maddie in the beauty
industry her business took a hit as it
was considered non-essential I thought
that when we were able to reopen the
they would let us reopen but then they
would shut us down after a week so it
was just like open and then close and
then open now three years later
thousands in the beauty industry will
come together in Las Vegas to learn from
and Inspire each other Victoria Saha
eight news now the show is happening
June 24th through the 26th at the Las
Vegas Convention Center around 20 000
people are expected to attend